welcome you on to this topic on docker
files here
in this one we are going to see that how
we can make use of the docker files to
prepare a docker image and
using which we can create a docker
container so
uh we are going to talk about what is a
docker what is a docker file
what is this index of docker file and
how to build a custom docker image with
the help of docker file
and in the end we are going to see a
particular demo related to the docker
files over here
now let's talk about what is the docker
now docker is in configuration
management tool which we are pretty much
using to prepare the
automation of the deployment of the
software of the applications
now in this case we make use of the
docker containers using which we can
host our applications
and within this docker containers we are
typically hosting both the
application source code and the defenses
all together so both the links
are getting packaged all together into a
single unit called docker containers
and getting hosted onto the server
these containers are very efficient in
work because they are not taking that
much
utilization and resources and at the
same time they can be
shared across different environments
also so the same container can be easily
deployed across different different
uh environments as such now it helps us
to maintain the isolated application
it helps in having a high productivity
there
and it also you know helps us to see to
resolve all the problems which is
related to the
uh dependencies for your software
because
we are packaging up both the source code
and the dependencies all together in the
single
unit in the single entity and that's
where you will be able to get a
particular final
solution called as in docker container
over here
so docker container is in complete
package using which you can have like
both the
applications and the dependencies bundle
up together into a single entity and
that's where we call it as a docker
container
now what exactly is an uh docker that uh
you know let's see a particular
difference between the virtual machine
and the docker here now if you see on
the left hand side we have the host
operating system
which is available there let's say i
have a laptop in this one we have a
windows 10
now we have a hypervisor on top of that
like how hypervisor is in software which
is used to manage the virtual machines
it's a software which is available there
which takes up all the requests from the
virtual machines
process it and then give the response
back
so hypervisor acts like a medium between
the virtual machine and the
host operating system resources so it's
going to give that a particular virtual
environment to the
virtual machines and then we have a
virtual machines where in fact a guest
operating system is there
then application binaries then the
application is hosted
so this guest operating system actually
takes up a lot of
utilization and these was the old
mechanism
where we used to uh follow this
mechanism for hosting our applications
so all the applications are pretty much
getting deployed in the same manner on
the form of the virtual machines here
right now if you talk about the new
method which we are talking about right
now is in docker so here we have host
operating system
but instead of hypervisor we have now
the docker engine which is available
there
now this docker engine is something
which is making sure working in the same
way that how the
hypervisor is behaving but it's much
lighter as compared to the hypervisor so
docker is very lightweight as compared
to the hypervisor here
and here we don't have the concept of
the heavy duty guest operating system
over here
so the guest operating systems which we
are using in case of docker containers
are very small in size
the size of guest operating systems is
is in gbs in case of virtual machine but
in case of docker containers it's pretty
much available in the mb
size which is there so the size of the
guest operating system in case of the
virtual machine is really small
as compared to the virtual machine and
that's a biggest
benefit because again it will help the
containers to have a
low utilization low consumptions and
that improves the overall performance of
the
overall mechanisms and how exactly the
new method of application deployment
really helps us to go for an
a particular advanced mechanism so that
brings on a
very good and the efficient uh
way of doing the deployment of the
applications
now let's talk about what exactly is in
docker file here
now uh docker file is a concept which is
being used as in build script
so it's being used so that we can have a
build a script there
so this will definitely helps uh to see
that how
we can go for a build of a docker image
a custom docker image
now when we are using the dockerfile uh
concept so it really helps to
uh prepare a kind of docker image
so doc image is the end result when you
are going for the
mechanism when you are going for the
docker file build up here
so docker file is a build script which
is available for preparing the custom
docker containers
because not every docker image is
available on docker hub so some
containers you have to use some
images you have to use to work on that
part now docker file is a very simple
straightforward text file which is
available there
and it's basically used to build up
custom docker images
so docker file is basically used to
prepare a once
so when you're running the docker build
so it's actually going to build up
a particular custom docker image and
that will be given to you
so docker uh image is the whole build
process which is being done
so it's a custom process which is
available and being done
over here in this case so
you got a docker file you run the docker
build command and that's how you will be
able to get a docker image
so whatever the steps you are having in
the docker file that will be processed
one by one
and as a end result you will be able to
get a full flesh docker image over here
in this case
right now let's talk about the syntax of
the docker file so docker file is equal
to
commands commands and the arguments so
whatever
the things you want to put up so in the
docker file you can do that and as a
part of the execution so you will be
able to get a particular end result
now it's a kind of a mechanism where we
feel that how the execution and the
modifications can be done
so uh the uh comments which we are
trying to do over here is that you know
we can put up the whatever the comments
we want to put
in the case of docker files we can do
that comments is a standard process in
uh preparing any particular file or
any kind of code because it helps us to
understand that
for what reason we are preparing that
particular line then uh we have the
uh particular run statements the
commands are there so you can see that
we are running a particular command
called eco so
using the run attribute we are basically
going ahead and running a particular
command into our system
as part of our docker file over here
now how to build up the docker images
using the docker file
so um you know docker file is uh just a
template
which is available there where we are
putting up that what are the different
steps we want to follow
and these steps when we follow one by
one step by step so that's where we will
be able to get a particular final docker
container over here
so docker image is getting converted as
a docker container and we are getting a
docker container as an end result
now um docker file is being built up and
uh stored in the version control system
and uh this particular docker files
when we are processing so it prepares a
respective
a specific image layer over here and
this image layer is something which is
uh benefiting us that how the executions
can be done and how we can
manage on that part so that really helps
us to see that how the executions and
the things can be managed and that can
help us to see that how the management
of the things can be performed as such
so uh dockerfile is a very good concept
which is there using which you can
prepare any kind of custom docker image
and it can be very easily handle also
and it's in fully automated mechanism
you can use it
inside the cicd pipelines for automating
the docker images
right now it's a docker image is a layer
by lay mechanism which is there in which
we have multiple layers each and every
layer we are doing some specific
entry some specific task or some you
know changes we are trying to deploy in
part of our these layers right so
uh you can use the uh particular docker
build command
to perform the executions and you will
be able to get any particular response
an output will be given back to you so
docker file is basically helping you to
see that how the executions can be done
and you will be able to get an end
result over here so the docker image is
the final result which we are getting
when we are talking about the docker
file here
right so these are all read only formats
which are available you cannot modify
these directly but yes with the help of
docker file you can do whatever the
changes you want to deploy on these
docker images
right so uh this is a small example
where we are using a base image as an 1
to 18.04 so we are using the from
attribute to specify that yes we are
going to use the ubuntu 18.04 here
then we are pulling our the file
into the uh directory we are
transferring a particular file
inside the docker container and then we
are running our make command and then
cmd attribute is there using which we
can run the command on the runtime on
the docker container so
these are a very a basic example but
eventually when we are done with this
docker image
we will be able to get a four layer uh
docker image over here because there are
four steps
and then hence it will be providing you
a particular four
layers in your final docker image over
here
so layer by layer these changes will be
done during the build process
and in fact using the docker history
command you can see the layers these
layers information also
right so layer one is ubuntu 18.04 layer
2
is pull and the third layer is there
where we can run the
uh make command to you know run this
file which we have pulled on
and then the finally the last one is
there where we are running like using
the cmd parent
so the difference between run and cmd is
that cmd will run only when you run a
docker container
so run attribute will be executed during
the docker build part
so this is a pretty much is a way that
how we can go for the
execution of a docker file and how you
know we can go for the
uh build up of a custom docker image
over here so these are the
for some couple of attributes which we
are using in the docker file
here right now let's talk about the
entry point over here now entry point
allows you to specify a command
along with the parameters right so let's
say that you want to
run a particular command uh over here in
the docker container so entry point is
something which you can use to refer to
that
so application is the command which
you're trying to run and then you can
give some
arguments to that and argument one is
what you're trying to run over here
so entry point is very important because
that eventually helps to see that how
the executions can be done
and the implementations uh will be done
over here in this case
right so you can see like you can run a
command called eco and then you can use
the parameters also
it's not like only the commands can be
used but you can in fact use the
arguments also now add is an attribute
which is available in the docker file
which is primarily used to see
to uh transfer the files from the host
machine
inside the docker image now let's see
that you are trying to prepare your own
custom docker image
apart from the dependencies you need the
source code also right so
the source code needs to be transferred
inside the docker image and for that
reason
we can use the add attribute so add
attribute
requires a source and destination source
will always be
the path on which on the testing on the
host machine the
files are present so we can give that
and destination is the
folder which is available inside the
particular docker container where we
want to store the files
so you can use the example over here
just like this you can use
and you can give two entries one is the
source one is the destination
and once that is done so you will be
able to see your files
being stored up in the destination
directory once the final
docker image is prepared then we have
enb attribute
now enb is something which is used to
set up some environment variables
which is required of course for the
docker image
for the application which is running
inside the docker image
now environment variables are something
which you can hard core during the
docker build one
but using the when you are running like
when you're creating the docker
container
at that time also you can overwrite the
these environment variables
so environment variables are very
important because uh first
during the build process you can hard
code some values but if you really want
to change them during the runtime
that also is being supported by the
environment variables
so most of the times we use it as an
kind of a keep value pair
just like in in linux we use uh we used
to set up a particular environment
variable so
the key value pair is being used in case
of enb attribute maintainer is there
where we can
describe that what is the details about
the author these are the fields which is
available in the top so where we can
give the
the author name and the author you know
details
like email id and all so that we know
that who is the person who is
maintaining this
particular file and we can reach out to
them in case any issues are there for
the
docker files am right so that is what we
have here in this one so now we are
going to see that how we can go for a
small demo and docker
file and we can go for the
implementation of this
particular docker file and prepare a
custom docker image so let's just wait
on that part
so let's see some demo here now in this
one we have got two examples one is the
python one is the notice one
so first of all what we need to do is
that we need to process the python one
here so this is the sample
docker file which we have got here for
the python now all this one requires a
python file which is already present on
the server
and we are going to transfer we are
going to copy this content over here
that will this is the
specific docker file content which is
available to us and all we need to do is
that we need to
put this content across the server so
that we will be able to
build our custom docker image so let's
go back to the server
so here we have already got the python
file which is present so we have to
create a docker file here which will
have the
steps related to the docker image
preparation over here so we will be
including
some steps over here that these are the
different steps we want to configure we
want to set up over here in this one
so python 3.6.4 is the version of the
python which we want to configure
and then we are going to transfer some
files into slash app we are also setting
up the working directory as slash app
and ultimately we are running a command
called pip install flask to do the
installation of flash package
and then we are starting the uh specific
applications on that part
so i'm going to save this file and once
i save this file so all we need to do is
that we need to create a custom docker
image right
so right now there is no image which is
available over here and it's in complete
md instance so i'm going to run a
command called docker
build hyphen t python hyphen
m dot so docker build is the typical
command but hyphen t
is for the tag that what kind of docker
image you want to build and then
we are giving a image name and then we
are specifying dot over there
now once we are done with that so it
will pick up all the things one by one
the basic docker image is being pulled
down
then some sequence of steps is being
executed so it's a step-by-step process
which is happening over here in this
case
and we are then transferring some files
in the slash app and then ultimately
we are going for the pip install flask
so it's installing those packages
and at the end the final docker image
will be prepared and will be given back
to us so
we will be able to get this uh docker
images over here when we
run that command we will be able to find
out that we got our custom docker image
also available
and as you can see that the base of
darker image is also available in this
one
but yes we have added up like around 10
mb of work we have added
on top of this python uh base docker
image here so that's how we are able to
do the processing over here in this case
in this setup
so that's what we uh can do to prepare a
custom
environment of python with the help of
the docker file here
now let's see that we will be proceeding
on with the node.js to see that if
the node.js uh kind of setup also can be
done
now for node.js again of course we got
uh the uh
specific docker file which is present so
we can process that
but let's create a new folder over there
so
i'm going to create for a new node.js
folder so that we can create the work
all together in this one
so i'm going to run a command called npm
minute which is the command to
initialize any
empty project in case of node now you
can typically bring down some
real code also or you can say that i
want to process
an empty a project so you can give the
configurations you can give the custom
names
but i want to process with these as
default name itself
so ultimately it's going to uh create an
entries
like uh you will be able to see like all
these uh
values which we are not providing these
standards value will be picked up
for the uh specific code and at the end
you will be able to
get a package.json file created over
here in this one
now you can actually bring down the
steps that how you can perform or you
can build up a
custom node.js based docker image now
these docker files is giving you the
capability that you can
convert a full-fledged application which
is deployable
on the virtual machine you can actually
convert them
in the format of the docker containers
over here in this one so that's what we
are going to get
over here with this uh particular setup
are these mechanisms
so let's go back to the document and see
that what exactly we can copy the
docker file so we have got this docker
file over here so all we can do is that
we can copy this one
so once we copy this uh specific file
here so all we can do is that we can
transfer
uh these files into the onto the server
we can convert it into the docker file
there
so that we will be able to set up the
configurations and we can perform the
setup around that so docker file is
again we want to create and we want to
set up on that here so let's go back to
the server
so here we want to create a docker file
and we want to set up the files inside
that these are the different files which
is being
available which is being configured over
here in this one so we are running like
node
server.js which is a master file so we
are doing an expose of 8080
then of course we have a copy commands
which is there
then npm install command is there and
then package.json file is also there
now what you need to really do is that
you need to go for a server.js file
which is available
in which you can configure that how the
setup needs to be done and how the
configurations
should be performed there because that's
a command that's a script which is going
to be executed within the
container so let's copy the content now
i'm going to copy this
content over here which is like a sample
node.js code which is available so i'm
just copy this one and transfer it to
the server
so server.js file we have to create here
just like we did in case of the python
because this is the source we want to
transfer inside the
docker container so this is what we have
got now i'm going to
uh transfer like uh i want to change
this port value from 5000 to
8080 because that's what it's configured
in the docker file
of course you can configure 5000 also
depending on your requirement you can do
that configurations
now you have got uh these two files over
here in this one so all you need to do
is that you need to run like docker
build
hyphen t node.js hyphen app
and dot so it will automatically pick up
like what exactly
it will uh you know go for the node.js
basic docker image over here so that
will be processed over here in this one
so step by step it will be able to do
the configurations
so first of all it will download the
basic docker image which is um
quite uh more in size over here in this
one
once it's downloaded onto your system
then it will proceed further with the
build activity on
processing the docker file performing
the execution so all that stuff will be
performed with this help of this docker
build process over here so it's going to
process it one by one in this one
and it's going to the next step where
it's transferring some of the
files like creating some working
directory transferring the files
uh putting up there and running the npm
install command
and uh then ultimately it will expose
the port and then it will
have the cmd attribute configured over
there so this is basically typically
trying to portrait it how a particular
docker image can be built up
and of course once the build is
successful you can
validate it with the help of docker
images here so this
is the app docker image which has been
prepared of 911 mb
and uh we have got it like a final
package where the runtime is also there
and the code base is also available now
you can pretty much
experience it like with other actual
source codes like you can generate the
download some pre-configured node.js
websites or
the source codes here and you can try to
run them onto the docker container
so that you can get the full uh the
complete idea about that how it goes on
but right now
the uh these are the basic docker image
which you can prepare
and you can build up over here in this
one so that's how it really works on for
you
so that was the demo which was there on
the docker file and
uh that helps us to understand that how
we can prepare a custom docker image
with the help of docker build command
and a docker file so that's it for this
one thanks everyone
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here